we before we get into our the bulk of
our interview I I just wonder if I can
ask you given World mental health days
is tomorrow we often forget that
politicians are human beings too how's
it been for you um it's been 19 hour
days seven days a week not just for me
for my officials across the department
we've been operationalizing many of the
schemes that the chancellor has
announced the bounceback loans the uh uh
coronavirus business Interruption loans
the future fund so it's been fullon
obviously to getting the uh different
guidelines for businesses into place as
well um but I think it's equally the
same for everyone else the front line
the NHS care workers so uh this is you
know the whole country has come together
it's a it's a tough time I mean
certainly your your business is is kind
of like mine can be quite matcho at
times I I don't know whether you feel
the same as me but it certainly feels
like we can all talk about it rather
more than we were able to just a few
years ago I think so and I think I think
actually you know there's been a step
change I've been in Parliament for 10
years um and a few years ago many of my
colleagues Charles Walker being one
stood up very bravely in Parliament um
DEA Davidson one of the new intake uh a
few weeks ago did the same thing and
just talked about it I think actually
that is you know part of sort of the
first step of being able to to deal with
this and of course we've put more money
into Mental Health Services in NHS as
well I think it's about 13 billion now
uh and will continue to increase in the
years to come as well uh well let's talk
very specifically about Co we understand
uh that there may well be some changes
coming I mean just just how bad are
things in the north at the moment it's
pretty difficult um if you take last
Thursday I'm going to give you National
numbers in the north as well last
Thursday infections were just shy of
7,000 uh this Thursday just gone um it
was 177,000 so that jump in seven days
from just shy of seven 17,000
just puts it I hope in some perspective
for your audience as to where we are at
in the North in cities like Liverpool
Manchester Newcastle we're sort of
touching about 500 infections per
100,000 um uh uh uh population so it's
pretty difficult uh Chris witty shared
some uh charts yesterday with um uh MPS
uh from the north just to demonstrate
how difficult the situation ised and I
want to get to the specific of that just
in just a say but but just in terms of
of what is going to change we heard from
Jillian Keegan your ministerial
colleague last night that Corona virus
is getting out of control your comments
Chim with that so so what is going to
change what will the north of England
look like this time next week in terms
of restrictions well one obviously we
keep these things under review daily
it's a fast moving situation we discuss
this with the public health uh local
teams uh to make sure that we're doing
the right thing and then uh make those
decisions so uh you you've seen the the
decisions up to date then you know we
can go further to try and suppress the
virus uh you know more what I won't do
is to speculate about what happens in
the coming days but certainly we're
we're keeping an eye on um all of the
areas uh as as we deal with the
infections I I suppose to point that
many people will be shout shouting at
the screen at the moment you know if as
Jillian Keegan says things are out of
control if it's Nadine Doris you know
who an interest in medical matters of
course you know saying that we are at
Hospital admissions could be reaching a
a critical stage in the next few days
why are we not acting no well we are I
mean this is the whole thing with local
leadership teams we've acted in terms of
uh social interaction in the home we've
acted in terms of the 10 p.m. curfew and
of course table service only in
restaurants and cafes uh and bars um and
as I said we keep all these things under
review and I think it would only be
correct that the health secretary uh
presents this uh if we are going to go
further to Parliament in the usual way
and of course to you and your colleagues
in the media well who who who who in Al
then is talking to the newspapers take a
look at any of them today they have
clearly been briefed by people working
in government perhaps not an elected
office but they've been briefed by
people working in government when the
Speaker of the House of common said it's
atrocious frankly that we are having to
find out what the government's strategy
coming up is you know I sitting down and
watching the sky news paper review at
night what is going on and why won't you
get to grips with this well I one I
think you will agree with me that these
leaks are completely counterproductive
you know whoever is leaking this stuff
is doing a disservice to the to the
service you asked me earlier about you
know what's happening on the front line
you're doing a disservice to the to the
service by you speculation and Leakes I
think that's wrong I think the right
thing to do is wait for the uh decisions
that the government will'll always
attempt to make sure that we do in a
coordinated way with the local teams we
you honestly sitting here and telling me
this morning that all of the briefing
that is taking place is happening
without any ministerial oversight that
no Minister has instructed their staff
to put this stuff out there because it's
it's it's farcical I can promise you
that this minister or no Minister would
actually instruct any member of Staff um
to go out and actually brief this stuff
out terrible it would be the biggest
leak Quire in the history of White Hall
well and and rightly so in the sense
that this is this is really bad uh that
people are are are leaking this stuff um
and I hope that whoever's doing this
will will stop because actually it's
counterproductive it's confusing and
it's
corrosive the problem is this you know
you can accuse the first minister of
Scotland Nicholas sturgeon of many
things one of them cannot be in action
she has moved forward on making sure
that the hospitality sector is is being
restricted in a manner that she feels
will will will halt well slow the spread
of covid-19 you guys are working with
the same data sets why are we not doing
it at the same time well first of all
there is a lot of coordination um so
there's a lot that is in common between
us then what what sort of separates us
on the interventions we're making of
course this the scientific advice is
devolved at Scotland Wales uh and
Northern iseland and therefore they make
their own decision rightly so in
coordination where ever possible sure
sure but Scottish government has acted
so 16 days of these restrictions which
means three weekends you know where
people will not be heading to the pubs
and restaurants and potentially
spreading covid we are told or we are
reading in the newspapers that we're not
going to take any action until Monday
why are we not acting now well we are
acting so so the not in terms of the
hospitality well we are we table service
only uh other than in takeaways 10:00
curfew um in England and and Wales
Northern Island stay at 11:00 we review
all of our interventions and we look at
at the data Chris wiy shared the data
with Northern MPS yesterday um you can
see where the spikes taking place which
demographic where it's coming from so
hospitality is about 30% of the
infection rate so there I mean there's
real evidence Now isn't there that the
hospitality sector is a major
contributor to the to the spread of Co
isn't well hence why we took the action
of table service only and uh restricting
uh the time to 10 p.m. uh curfew not
something that uh I certainly took uh
easily because I think these businesses
have tried very hard to be Co safe uh
but clearly it's something that we have
to do to stop us having to go into a a a
a sort of you know National lockdown or
much harsher set of interventions but
given but given that there is the
evidence regarding the hospitality
sector at the moment why do the
chancellor sitting there in that seat
earlier this week accuse me of coming to
you know simplistic conclusions when I
had the edity to suggest that perhaps
you know paying people to go to pubs
restaurants and bars which we are going
to be seeing closing down in the north
of England at some point next week that
might have contributed to co well first
of all in the summer uh the restaurants
that participated in in which I think
what you're referring to the eat out to
help out yes scheme did it in a safe way
they did it in a covid safe way and we
didn't see the sort of spikes that we
saw much later in coming through in
September and then Chris Wht speaks to
150 MPS yesterday in a dark room with a
slideshow that shows that the
hospitality is responsible for 30% of it
so the social interactions within
hospitality and in the home is clearly a
problem at the moment which is why we're
acting on these things and I think
that's that's a responsible thing to do
Neil why is it though that there has
seem been seemed to be on a number of
occasions a lag Factor we were told at
the beginning of all of this that there
would be more coordination between the
Nations can can you honestly say that
you know mayors of Greater Manchester
are as happy with the way things are
going in England as local Authority
leaders are in Scotland well I think my
job our job is to make sure that we work
with the local leadership teams and we
do that um on a daily basis um Public
Health local teams um have the best
knowledge of their locality hence why we
listen to them hence why we work with
them now you know you're not going to
get everything right some Mayors Andy
Burnham's clearly you upset uh with
certain
we have to continue to work together I
think in the National interest we have
to set aside politics it's unfortunate
that you know K starm and some of his
team see it as an opportunity you know
never let a good crisis go to way I
think that's heartbreaking in many ways
um I think we've got to continue to work
together my message to all local leaders
no matter what party they belong to is
we have to continue to work together you
seeing other countries you just said on
on your opening piece about France and
other countries having to go even
further now because the virus is is even
higher than where where we are at at the
moment so we have it is incumbent on all
of us to come together and make sure we
control this virus we we're we're
approaching the end of our time together
so I just want to slightly change topic
and and and move on to one which we've
discussed a number of times on various
programs here MPS pay once again we're
hearing from the Independent
parliamentary standards Authority that
you're going to get a three grand pay
rise at a time when people are losing
their jobs in their Millions isn't it
about time to ask the question whether
or not ipsa actually is fit for purpose
well an
independent body has to be the right way
forward hence why ipsa was set up it is
do you think a is appropriate right I
don't think a pay rise is appropriate I
then it's not fit for purpose i' I've
been a minister for now coming on three
years and I don't have a ministerial
salary but I I I think it's a privilege
in many ways to serve your country but
nevertheless um I think it's right that
it's independent and they have to also
explain themselves because they also
exist in the court of public opinion
opinion and so yes of course you it's
much better than the old system you know
before I came into Parliament it used to
be parliamentarians who decide these
things under the old system you guys
would not have voted through £3,000 of a
pay R that's the biggest failure with
this system well it as I say it's
independent but I think it's incumbent
on the leadership of RSA to also explain
to you know the public because we all
exist in the you know in in the same
sort of social fabric of society in the
court of public opinion is important as
to why they think this is the right
thing to do would you give it back
donate it to a food bank I would
certainly look at uh donating it to one
of my very good causes maybe the
Shakespeare Hospice in Stratford